外国語
[音楽]
こんにちは、ようこそ皆さん、
これは actinf ライブ ストリーム番号
47.0 です。2022 年 8 月 3 日
です。アクティブ
な推論研究所へようこそ。 スライドのリンクのいくつかで私たちを見つけてください。
これは記録され、アーカイブされ、
転写され、ライブで公開されている
ため、フィードバックを提供して、作業を改善できるようにしてください。
すべての背景と視点を
歓迎します。ライブのビデオ エチケットに従います。
ストリーム
アクティブな推論機関の
活動はすべて参加型
です。貢献したい場合や
参加したい場合は、
activeinference.org にアクセスし、リンクをクリック
して直接参加してください。
いつものように 1 つの論文について議論し、並置するのでは
なく、複数の視点を開いたアプローチで議論します。
この状況での 2 つの論文に向けて
、並置された方法で学び、議論する予定です。2021 年の 2 つの論文では、
アクティブな推論と誘拐について
ati vaiko
pieteren と majid beni
が取り上げます。また、アクティブ
な動的社会的認知と
ines によるアクティブな推論についても議論します。  hippolyto と thomas
van s も 2021 年から、
すべてのビデオは
ドット ゼロであり、それ以外は
、これらのアイデアの紹介と
追加のコンテキストであり、レビュー、
評価、または最終的な
言葉ではありません。
非アクティブな人のための水色
統合のいくつかの領域を示す新しい色と組み合わせが発生するためのスペースを開いたままに
しておきます。このドットゼロ
でいくつかの大きな質問について話し、
目標を確認し、それらの目標の間を読みます
これは
多くのライブ ストリーム
と
は少し異なります dmap
とアブストラクト
は、次にコンテキスト セクションの背景に移動します。この
セクション
には、
不作為の記号論、アブダクティブ
ロジックに関する多くの情報が含まれ
ます。その後
、2 つの論文
の並置に移動します。 今後のディスカッションで
複数の著者と議論する時間がたくさんあることを願っています.1.2
そしておそらくそれ以降.
最初の並置と
これらの論文を
ざっと見てみると、誰かが論文を読むことに再び
興奮し、より深く掘り下げて、
これらの非常に興味深いトピックに独自の視点をもたらすので
、紹介に移りましょう。
私はダニエルです。 カリフォルニアの研究者で
、次のスライドで何がエキサイティングかについてもっと話します。それをディーンに渡します。
おはようございます。私の名前はディーンです。私は
カルガリーにいます。
このアイデアをまとめようとしたゆがんだ心と
、一見異なるように見えるフォークフォーカスの2つの異なる論文
を引き出そうとすることで、アクティブな推論の見方を少し変更し、
それらの両方
にアクティブな推論の使用も組み込んでいます。
状況に応じて分析するための方法論として、それが意味することは何
ですか。それで、それは本当にエキサイティングだと思います。スティーブンに伝えます。ディーンに感謝します。はい、スティーブンです。
カナダのトロントにいます
これらの論文
は両方とも
、一般的な参加型アプローチと、
人々がどのように世界に関与しているかについて多くのこと
を
語っている
ため、これらの論文に非常に
興味を持っています。
どちらもまったく異なる
論文ですが、どちらも
私に非常に強く話しかけているので、とても
興味深いので
、
それを探求できることを楽しみにしています. 私は
参加型劇場
コミュニティ心理学コミュニティ
開発とマルチスケール開発プロセスに取り組んでおり、
この科学的見解
が実践ベースの参加型質問と呼ばれるものにどのように対応できるかを見るのが本当に楽しみです.
ずっと
見てきたので、ダニエルに返します。
素晴らしいお二人とディーンに感謝
し
ます。私たちが歩んできた多くの電子メールと月とメッセージの旅。
ライブストリームと、私たちが
行った場所を超え
て取り組んでいる種類の資料を使用する方法で
あり
、その精神で、学部長を渡して、
ここでいくつかの大きな質問を紹介し
ます。 主題の
点であまり共通点
がないように見える論文は
、論文の内容を見つけるだけでなく、
これらの論文をどのように
比較するか
ということ
で、状況分析
ツールまたは
現実の方法のいずれかのアクティブな推論が
、遠く離れているように見えるもの
を引き離してそれらを絡ませるのにどの
ような役割を果たし得るかについて、いくつかの質問をまとめました。 質問は基本的に、
アクティブな推論は、
何かを保持するか、含むか、または
制限するものの両方であり、また、
アクティブな推論とは
何か、または含まれているものの両方をアクティブに強調する場合
は、テーブル内のパーティショナー行と言う
セルの
ように、
実際により多くの情報を実際に入れることができる実際のギャップは
、制約とセパレーターの両方として
同時にどのように見える
かを示します。
次のいくつかのライブ
ストリームと、モデルを把握する上での類似点または相違点
と、モデリングの異なるプロセスについて
スティーブンに感謝します ここに何かを追加
する必要はあり
ません。
それは多くのことをカバーしていると思います。
そこにある x は、フレームワークを
モデル化する推論モデルをアクティブにできることを示す
ようなものです。
再生しますが、それ
については少し後で説明します。ありがとう
ございました。
これは
、このレベルに戻るのに役立つことを
願っているため、最初の目的のスライドの 1 つになる可能性があります。
片手で拍手した 2 つの論文を
2 つにまとめます。ライブ ストリームからすでに音が聞こえ
ます。特に
ディーンを聞いている場合は、ラムズについて何を説明しますか。
または、どのように
要約
しますか ああ、rna ames について追加するもう 1 つのメモは、
包括的であるだけでなく、
聞き取り可能で適切な
時間の長さのビデオを用意して、多くのスライドが存在するようにすることです。
紙からコピーされた多くのテキストがあり、読み
たい場合はビデオを一時停止する
だけです
が、
本当に確認したかった多くのテキストスライドから先に進みます. すべての
テキストは目に見えませんでした
が、すべてを読むつもりはない
ので、ディーン ええと、これらの
目的の何
について話したいか
を要約してください。 これらの箇条書きの 1 つは
、
リアリズム インストル
メンタリズムの議論を詳しく見ていき
ます。参加したことがある場合は、それ
が何であるかを説明する必要はありません。
一方の目は
、アクティブな推論論文のペアから非アクティブ
な動的な社会的状態
と拉致を取り込み、
もう一方の目
は両方のインテグレーターとしてアクティブ
な推論を示します。
織りまたは
3 番目の箇条書きは、モデルの時間的な深さを理解する最初の 2 つのことを行う
場合、絶対的な必要性を明示します。これは
、
2 つの異なる主題
に積極的に推論を行う際に、一見遠いトピックの 2 つの論文を実際に組み込むことになります。 次に、私たちが行ったことは、著者が論文について指摘した
さまざま
な事柄を
抽出したことです。スティーブンに感謝します。
これらの目的の間を読んだり、
このスライドから好きなものを追加したりしていただければ幸いです。
ええ、ダニエルに感謝し
ます。 著者のセットは
、あなたが知っていることを知っていると言っています 道具主義を本当に見ていることを知っていて、それが有効な科学的視点であることを知っていることを知っていますが、そこにあることを知っていることを知って
います。
道具主義とは
、この科学的研究をうまく捉える方法、
または自分自身を保持
する方法です。 挑戦
されて、参加型アプローチに入るとき、それを緩める必要があるかもしれない方法がわかるでしょう。
その間にある何かがその科学的空間を緩め
、実践空間であるため
、2番目のポイントと同じ
です。 器楽主義
ええと、あなたは前進する方法を知っています
ニッチに住むときの行動を構成するものは何か 生き物を
構成するものは何ですか
ええと、
どのように前進するかを解決する方法 矛盾
がある場合は、それらを調整する必要があります 私たちが
しようとしているチームにいる場合 これを使用
して、それらと一緒に暮らして
前進する必要がありますか、実際にそれらを強調する
必要があるので、これはある意味
で、科学的
哲学的点に焦点を当てたこの種のレーザーの焦点の外で、ええと考えようとしているときに大丈夫です。
私たちはこれらをチームのコンテキストに持ち込もうとしています.
その一部を緩める必要が
あり
ます.
アクティブなインプリントが前書きまたは
接尾辞として付けられていることはご存知のとおり、適応型のアクティブな
影響効果的なアクティブな影響または
アクティブな推論モデリング
は、その明確化がいかに重要であるかを知っており
、次に
、道具
主義のリアリズムの作品がこれらの他の方法でどのように利用される
かについても考える必要がありますか? ええと、
あなたは完全に別のものを完全に知って
おり、私たちがその間にいる
場合、コンテキストに基づい
て知ることへのアクセスが多かれ少なかれある可能性がある
ことを知っ
ています。
の
は、共同創造的な仕事についての私自身の考えに少し語っています。
ええと
、ダニエルはチーム
や
ディーンと非常に多くの変革を行って
いることを知っています。共同創造の作品があることがよく
あります。
あなたは蝶をつぶさずに支えたいと思っています。
そこには
非常にデリケートな
ものがあります。
o-創造的な空間
では、より微妙な文脈上の方法でモデリングが行われている場所
を知っています。これらの
科学的定義と戦略的
設計と厳密な分析が
あり、それらは有用ですが、起こっていることを押しつぶしたくありません。
そこにある写真
はそれ
を物語っています。おそらくディーンに渡します。
その間にある水のサンプリングと心のギャップについて話すことができ
ます。
それは美しい説明だったと
思います。
著者が着手できるように
なっ
たら、これに色を付けることができるようになるでしょう。地面に
アンカーをいくつか置いたと思います
が、どのくらいの流れがあるかはまだ述べていません。
これらの異なるノード間を移動でき
ます。これが私たちが
ここで確立したかった
ことだと思います。地下鉄で
あなたを殺すことができる唯一のもの
は、注意を払っていないからです
が pと私は
、その間の水のサンプリング
は同じことをすると思います
が、それらの種類のギャップの流動性に関して少し異なる微妙な違いを提供することを除いて、
それをポータルとして使用する場合、それは本当に興味深い
と思います. 部屋
の反対側の椅子に座っているときに、物事をまとめて踊らせる方法について。ドット 1 と 2 から始めると
興味深い会話になるかもしれません。
お二人に感謝します。唯一のコメントです。
ここに追加して、適応的感情などの能動的推論の前
にある形容詞について私たちが行ってきたこの議論を追加し
、次に
x という接尾辞に焦点を合わせ、
能動的推論モデルを 1 つのインスタンス
またはケースまたは実現
能動的推論として括弧で囲みます。 フレームワーク アクティブな
推論プロセス 理論 何が
続くのか これは
、文法と構文における左分岐節と右分岐節を本当に思い出させ
、ベース c があることを思い出します
私たちの基本節とは何か、そして
前と中と後の分岐は何か
、非常に豊かな空間があると思います。
これらの具現化さ
れたフラックスベースのメタファーが本当に好きで、非常に理解するのに役立ちます。
論文の概要では、
これは単なるメタデータとなります。
背景
に戻る前に論文の説明を読んで
から、主要なポイントを通過する論文に
進むので、抄録を読むつもりはありません
。
能動的
推論と誘拐
ここに非
能動的動的社会的認知と能動的推論の要約
があります ここに両方の
のキ
ーワードがあります 非能動的論文にはキーワードがあ
ります キーワード
アブダクション 能動的推論 自由エネルギー
原理 最初とブランケット
トライアド関係と突き刺す
アブダクション論文の目的と主張に行きましょう。
ディーンは
、アブダクション論文の目的のいずれかをカバーし
たいと思いますか?私がし
たいことは、両方の論文の目的と
それ この記事の
2 番目の箇条書きに
同盟というキーワードが表示され
ます。それから、別の論文に表示される単語があります。そこでは、
物事をまとめたいと言って
いますが、 連想関係があると
私たちが信じている2つの2つ以上のもののブレンドとして比喩的に認識されたくない
ので、私たちが
どのように一緒になることを説明するかに注意してください。 この 2 つの論文の目的を
少し振り返ってみると、
両方の論文の著者が、
どのような
関係
に注目してもらいたいかについて厳しい説明を行っている
ことがわかります。 論文
はそれが重い強調であることを共有しています
関係の
素晴らしい点であり、どちらも非常に
豊かで強力に書かれて
おり、ここでは同盟と忠誠
が見られます。確かに
、両方の論文で、
異なるまたは部分的に
関連するオントロジーと語彙セット
、および異なる思想家の異なるスレッドを統合することについて多くの議論が行われるでしょう。
知的発達の
これらの論文からの引用は読むことができ
、もちろん論文で拡張されてい
ます
が、ディーンが言ったように、この論文の焦点は
能動的推論と自由エネルギー
原理fepの間の知的同盟であり、主にCS pierceの仕事
の観点から 記号論 語用論
文法主義 アブダクティブ ロジック
目的の合成は
、相乗効果のある方法でこれら2つをまとめ、
意味を提供
して
います コンピュータでシミュレート
するのが非常に難しい領域を調べます。
拉致が起こる方法、
特に人間との関係は
非常に洗練されており、
実際
に
劇場の超音波検査やセットデザインと
プラグマティズムで多く使用されている記号論を見ることは
本当に役立つと思います。 それはあなたが知っていることですが、
科学を超越することはしばしば自然科学の
ように他の分野で
使用されます
が、それは人文科学で使用されることが多いので、
これは
その種の秘密のソースが明らかにされていることについてその作品に話していると思います.
その種の魂へのヒットは
通常欠けており、実際
に
は、論文の素晴らしい主張
が論文全体にあるようなものもあり
ますが、彼らが設定した目的であると彼らが主張している重要な主張のいくつかを強調するだけです
能動的推論の仕事と
、アブダクションと記号論的観点との間で、
彼らは、それが
実現可能であり、最初の情報を提供していると主張しているようです
新しいものと古い
もの、赤いもの、青いもの、青いもの、
新しいもの、古いもの、そしてそれぞれ新しいものと古い
ものの2つのフレームワークのこの理論的な理論的統合は
、自由エネルギーの原理によって表される神経科学
と認知科学の現代的なインスタンス化です。 古い歴史的に正確
で正確なアブダクティブ
推論の解釈には、研究の経済の重要性が含まれ
ます.私たちが戻ってくるすべての
ことは、主張を明確にしたかっただけです
.1つだけ追加できますはい.
私たちが私たちの目的について話していたときのことを考えてみてください。
問題は、これが
著者が言って
いることです。私たちが疑問に思っていることは
、統合製品と統合者の両方がプロセスを積極的に推論することです。
その一歩をちょっといじりたいと
思ってい
ます。 別の論文
では、彼らは異なる命名法を使用しますが、
彼らは同じことを言うでしょう。
繰り返し
ますが、あなたとあなたがそれらを作り上げる必要がない限り、共通点を見るのは難しい
です.
2 つの異なるタイプのフォレスト
と、それらの
両方がアクティブな推論
をインテグレーターとして、また差別化ツールとして使用しているという
点です。それらを区別し、もちろん統合することにより
、内部および
外部のブランケット状態の統合モデルを作成しています。
と
微分は、
数学では積分
と導関数の表記法と一緒に使用
されるため、多くのことが一緒になるでしょう。
ええと、
スティーブンはまだあなたの手が上がっ
ています。
この計算神経科学における
神経科学とそれを強調する
ために、私は
何か
が世界の現実であると考えているので
、これらのアイデアがどこにあるかという文化があります。 循環している
ということは、神経科学
は基本的に分野としての神経科学に
積極的に影響を与えることによって頭を
悩ませているという
こと
です。人々は、この予測的な旅とは対照
的に、何かが
入ってき
て評価され
具体化されるある種の演繹的なプロセスであることを理解し
ています。
これは
私たち全員が直面し
ているものであり、神経科学者と話をしたときに気づいた
ことは、彼らは実際
に実存的危機のようなものを抱えていて、積極的
でない
主張を思いつき、実際に 非アクティブな
主張はあります.神経科学との彼らの研究をどのように
まとめて
いるのでしょうか.
一般的なものに関連する部分がここにあります.専門分野から活発な影響を引き出し始めると
、その一般的な
部分がより重要
になり
ます. それは一種の
飛び地であり、そのゲームのルールは
知られており、
人々が神経科学をよく言う分野に入っています 私はそれが何
を
意味するかを
知っています.
生物学は
、進化の光を除いて、または何かの光を除いて
意味があります。これらは
、その島々に戻る2つの光であり、その間のスペースは何ですか。
次に
、研究の経済とその自由
エネルギーの帰化、結論
と うさぎの穴を突き刺す
すぐに非アクティブな論文に
入る予定なので、ここでは
、非アクティブ
な動的社会的認知とアクティブな
推論
論文のエイムズの主張とロードマップについて説明します。 フォールドの目的
は、アクティビズムと推論的な説明が混ざり合った新しい説明を分析し
、なぜそうすることで矛盾が生じるのかを説明することです。これ
が最初の目的で
あり、セ 条件の目的は、特にこの社会的認知の場合に
、行動主義と推論のアカウントにリンクする唯一の合理的なアカウントを提供することです。
そのため
、私が望んでいたことを推測しないでください。
リンクする単語を
私たちのために紫に変えてください。はい、ありがとう、私たち
はさまざまな方法を持っています
私たちが実際に論文自体を見始める前に、スティーブンが強調する素晴らしい仕事をしたことを説明し
ます。
ええ、それは間にあり
ます。それは素晴らしいことです。実際には、あなたの要求とスライド
プラットフォームを通じて、アクティブで動的な
社会的スティグマギー
になります。
これは何の概念実証ですが、これがこの論文の目的です。
彼らはまた
、議論全体を通して明確にされた多くの主張を持って
おり、実際には非常に明確な表記法を使用して
、他の研究や自身の研究からの特定の主張
と、どの主張について説明しています。 そして仮説
はどのような論理関係を持っているかというと、
彼らは認知の性質とその性質について主張しようとしているのです。
彼らは
、人間の社会的認知ニッチに関連するいくつかの主張について議論し、人間
関係の文化化ニッチ
構築の重要性について話し
、次に
、心の理論と
互換性または矛盾について話します。
非アクティブな
主張
を心の理論または推論アカウントに関連付けることに関連して
、論文の
ロードマップはこれらの目的の多くをレイアウトし、
非常に明確に主張している 紹介から始まり、他の心のフレーム
ワークによる思考であるアクティブな推論分野で最近の影響力のある研究を紹介する
トム
と彼らが言うように、彼らはこの
説明
を分析して、
彼らの見解で
は非アクティブなカウントと推論カウント
が一緒にされた方法を分解しようとして
います.また、マルコフブランケットを説明する図も持って
います.
彼らの論文の
セクション 2 の非アクティブな推論を拒否する何かを与える必要があります。
他の考えを通して
、彼らは 2 つの仮定
、つまり、社会的認知が
精神的表象に還元されるという仮説と、
社会的認知が生まれつき固定化さ
れているという 2 つの仮説を利用しようとしている。
動的システム理論を使用
し、その互換性の観点から dst をアクティビズムとどのように関連付けることができるか
、およびこれら 2 つの
フレームワークが道具主義者の読書の中で互いに何を提供するかについて話します。
次に動的システム理論
の文脈で特に能動的推論について議論し、
他方では
非能動的
認知社会的認知について議論します。これは非能動的
動的
ハイフネーション
であり、一般的に社会的非活動間の類似点と相違点についていくつかの数字で説明します。
アクティブな推論の外で概念化されたものとして
、それらは
アクティブな推論がそのイメージをどのように豊かにするかを視覚的に紹介するつもり
です。そして、自然界で観察された
現象と自然界で観察された
行動を区別する非常に興味深い表があります。 コンテキスト
セクションの背景なので、ドットゼロのこのセクションでは、
確かに論文からの引用を使用
しますが、一歩
下がって、奨学金と
研究の氷山の一角だけを示します。 この時点までに実行したことは
、リスナーまたは読者
を興奮させ、論文でアプローチおよび近似されるこれらの非常に深いスレッドに何らかのコンテキストを提供することを願って
います。ここで最初のメモを提供するか、ディーンは
行ってください
これは素晴らしい瞬間だと思います
ので、
背景と文脈について話しているので
、おそらく時間的および物理的な
設定について話している
ので、 これは現在、状況に応じて分析できるものであり、
アクティブな
推論を使用するかどうか、キャスト モデルを使用するかどうか、またはプロのイニシアチブ プログラミングを使用するかどうかは重要ではありません。
方法と、そして
これらの
方法のすべて
が、時間的および物理的な状況に応じて、多かれ少なかれ実行可能性があると想像する
ので、これらの論文のそれぞれが良いか悪いか
を私たちが言っているのではなく、それが重要なことだと思います
これらの各論文
は、少なくとも 2 つの異なる
背景コンテキストの組み合わせに焦点を当てて
いると言っているので、2 つのことを
一緒に
すると、同じことになるとは言え
ません。 まったく新しいエンティティを作成する
2 つの論文をそれぞれ並べて見た人々としての私たちの目的
を考え出してください。この背景とコンテキストをリードしていただきありがとうございます。
調整セクション 私
は私のお気に入りの職人の詩人の 1 人を呼びたいと思いました ウィリアム・
ブレイク
とブレイクは書いています
反対は肯定的です 否定は反対ではあり
ません
否定は反対ではありません 反対は
相互に存在します
が、否定は存在しません
このブレイクヤンの
4 つの論理的フレームワーク
における永遠に終わりの引用の反対は、実際に
は弁証法の一部であり、
凸面と凹面のように、または重力と放射のように互いの関数として存在します。
フレームワーク
は存在しないものであるの
に対し、a と b は反対である可能性がありますが、a と a では
なく異なる
論理関係を持ち、状態空間と真実を認識するためのこの種の
4 重の論理的アプローチ
は、複数の並置された
アサーションが持つことができると主張します
お互いの間
でも、多くの世界の知識の伝統で予測されてい
ます。 カタ・スコッティの例であり
、これは非常に長い間
適用されてきた論理的なツールと方法で
あり、インドのコンテキストのダルマの伝統がそれ
を提供したいと考えて
いました。 片手の拍手や
スプリット
をしている人は、矛盾と否定と関係があり
ますか はいディーン
矛盾に関してもそうです
これ
は文脈上の部分の種類を指していると思います
ええと 状況
分析の部分
は
内部に状況があります
そこには
矛盾が構築されてい
ます。それが理に
かなっていれば、それは私たちの生活を通じて具現化され、制定され
ている
ので、赤ちゃんのように
、さまざまな状況のさまざまな段階での子供の形態を知っている可能性があります。状況を確立する方法を提供し
ます。
物事が成文化されるにつれて、意識とその中の矛盾が生じます。
プロセスとは
、この進行中のモデリング フローの中で私たちが行っていることの
ようなものであり
、これらのさまざまな論文の中でそれらを支える
実践分野のようなものであり、非活動主義者は実践を
感じています。 私たちは何を
具現化し、入り込み、学び
、それを
直感的にモデル化し、これらの状況
でどのようにモデル化する必要があるかを感じ取っています
が、そのモデル化はしばしば矛盾しています。
誰かが自分のモデルを持っている人に圧倒され
ます。つまり、
誰か
が自分自身であるとはどういうことかをモデル化している、またはそれを処理しようとし
ている人がモデルを持っているカウンセラーに会いに行きます。
彼らの問題がどのように構成されているかを教えてくれるので、
このモデルモデルは
ここで
非常に関連性があると思います.
デルがそのドメイン内で作成され、その
ドメイン
に必ずしも属していない誰かが
モデルに帰することができ
ます。彼らはゲームが何であるかを知りません。彼らは
プロセスに参加しておらず、モデルが
引き継ぐため、スプリットに切り替わります。
それなら、私たちは一緒にいる2つのことを持っているので、私たちは
これについて話しているので、はい
、あなたが開いてみましょう。あなたはスタンスを持っています。
それはあなたが
そこに持っている分裂ですあなたは正しく注意しなければならない
ので、あなたは
今物事を開こう
と
しているという考えに入りました。 いくつかの点
で、それらは現在互いに分離されている方法で分割されて
います。
ご存知の
ように、それらを1つに
押し込まず、分割せず
、その間にスタンスをとらない方法を見つけようとしていると思います。
どういうわけかアジャイルであり
、この場合はリアリズムとインに関連してい
ます いくつかのより広いテーマを反映するようなトゥルーメンタリズム
ディーン
、本当にすぐに感謝しますええと、多くの人が
ヨギバロニズムを聞いたことがあります。
道路の分岐点を見たとき、
それを取ってください。
多くの用語でジョイント
が来たことを私は知っています たとえば、結合確率が大幅に増加する
ため、ここでの分割のアイデア
は、比喩的に言えば非常に優れたものです。
なぜなら
、アクティブな干渉のあるものを見ている場合
、お茶の迷路の実験では左右にうまく行かなければならないと想定しているからです。
人間
は道の分岐点を見つけてそれを取ること
ができます
私の足に分岐点があるのを見た場合、それはスタンディングジョークのようなものですそれらを取る
必要
はありませんオルビーを選択する必要はありませんあなたはすべてを取ることができます
そして私はそれがブレイクだと思い
ます この演習で指摘しようとして
いるのは矛盾
であり、道に道具が見えても
それを取ることができますが
、フォークが左または右だけを意味するわけではないという考えに心を開いていない
場合、私は Whに関してすでに自己制限されている
私は状況に応じて分析されているものをテストしてい
ます。より
直接的なキーワードの部分に感謝します。
したがって、thisdefinitions.net
サイトからのアクションでは、アクションは知識を整理する可能な方法の 1 つであり
、世界の非アクティブな知識との相互作用の形式の 1 つです。
行動から得られる知識であり、自転車に乗って物体
を操作したり、スポーツをしたりするなどの運動能力に基づいて構築され
ます。これは、提供されている多くの定義の 1 つにすぎ
ません。アクティブな推論における行動について、いくつかのライブ ストリームや論文での議論も行っています。
たとえば
、6 年前のアクティブなライブ ストリーム
では、2020 年
に 2 つの密度の物語についてラムステッドについて議論しました。
アクティブな推論はアクティブな推論
であり、
2021 年にはヒッポリトの論文についても議論し
ました。 いくつかの点でsaging まさにこの
議論です これは
そのライブストリームからのスライドです
ええと ヒッポリト紙
と ここでは、突き刺すような
トライアドがあり、象徴主義
と記号論とフランス語への言及が
あったので、実際には
非常に関連する表現の概念について話し
てい
ました。 非活動主義と推論
の説明に関する議論の上で、
表現と認知的表現の問題に大きく左右されます。
それらがどこにあるか、または
それらが存在するかどうかなどです
。
伝統的な社会的認知
と非活動的な社会的認知との違いのいくつかをすぐに彼らの見解でより多くの表現が見られる
ようになるので
、画像名の単なる視覚的解釈ではなく
、それを提供したいと思います
いいえ私は待っています あなたは次は
大丈夫だからここで私が見ているのは、
伝統的な社会的認知推論
アカウントで
はギア 脳内で回転
し、身体の中にある社会的実体をつなぐ知覚アクションループとリンケージがありますが、
身体はその種の情報を伝達するためのインターフェースのように見られ、
極端なスタンスまたは単純な視覚的
表現
を伝達します。
ギアは
、その間の空間のニッチの環境
を含め、どこにでもあるように見えます。そうです、脳は物事を行っています
が、それは、
この文化化された
社会的認知プロセスを
全体論的なフレーミングでもう少し実装している制定されたシステムの一部でもあります。 ディーン
はいはい、私は誘拐が
何について話しているのかを見ていきますが、
今の
ところ
、
これは一種の 時間的な
深さですが、その時間的な深さは
垂直
です。何百年もの長いタイムラインを見る拉致はより
水平だ
と思います。 時間的深さは王だが、
焦点は
横方向の広い時間的深さではなく、垂直または深い時間的
深さ
にある 両方とも重要だが、直交しているからといって、それらが互いに
競合していることを意味するわけではない
さまざまな方向で
私が言いたいのは
それだけです左と右または西と
東は反対の方向ですが、
それらは否定的な方向ではなく
、直交性、希薄性、または条件付き独立性がどのように
付与されたかがわかり始めるところです。 たとえば、マルコフブランケットによって、
否定ではなく反対
の枠組みでそれらをどのように見る
ことができるかということです
あなたが言っているように、環境の部分は間違いなくそこに
あり、明らかに分析の単位として
非常に挑戦的
であり、ギアの言葉としてそこに入れます
言葉は
けいれんです
私たちの声帯の魔女化は、私たちの
周りの空間に言葉を与えている
ので、それらがツールとしても使用されていることを知っている
ので、突然
、それが単なるスピーチであっても、はるかに巻き込まれます。
インターネットと
空間と
時間を通じて、社会的不活動についてもう少し深く掘り下げます。
この不活動の研究リソース
は、パフォーマンスにおける不活動のいくつかの意味と感覚と、
感覚を生み出すことについて説明しています。 そしてデハーン
は
、社会的認知における活動主義の関係のいくつかについて議論し、推論と非活動主義者の説明
がまとめることができるものを要約する素晴らしい仕事をし
ました。
ここで興味深いのは、彼ら
が橋の比喩を使用する場合
、アクティビズムには橋があると思います。
それは単なる垂直の橋です。
建物の側面が上昇
しているので
、
彼らがここに書いたことを批判しないわけにはいきません
が、
借金があり、スパンする能力があると思います。それは
垂直に進んでいるだけで、伝統的に横に並んでいるわけではありません。
アブダクションと記号論について少し深く掘り下げて、
私たちは一緒にかなりの学習の旅
をしました。著者の 1 人、1.5 人、または 2 人
がピアソンの真の専門家であるアブダクション論文の
多くの詳細を提供しました。
ピアスは多作の作家であり思想家でした。
つまり、
難解な参照システムがいくつかあり、その
すべてが非常にアクセスしやすいわけではないということです
このページの内容を要約したいの
は、プラグマティズムに興味があり、ウィリアム・ジェームズを
過去のものにしたい場合だけです。
ジェームスと
チャールズ・サンダース・ピアスは、
彼らがおそらく150年前に
、
物事がどのように機能するか
についての最初の対立者であっ
たということを少し持っ
ていました。 お互いに
賢くなっていますが、実際に
は150年
後の
私たちが今振り返っている多くのアイデアは、お互いに競争していると感じていたと言わざるを得ませんが、
彼らがしていたことは中継していたと思います または、
どういうわけか、彼らは常に同じ目を通して物事を見ているわけではなかったので、より良いモデルを構築していました.
彼らは両方の目を開いていました.
よく知られている
ピアソントライアド記号論フレームワークであり、一時
停止標識は表現と呼ばれます
表現された
インスタンス 物理的な一時停止標識 実際の
一時停止
標識 オブジェクトは混乱です age car must stop
here and the interpretant is i should
stop here and that is that entity Agency を取得する場所です
ユーザー インターフェイス
に関する興味深い論文を
見つけました
ユーザー インターフェイスの比喩に対するその記号論は、
それが現実世界の一時停止の標識であったか、それとも
ユーザー インターフェイス コンテキストの Web サイトのボタンであったかを想像することができ
、
誰もが一時停止して、
引用符からの非常に優れた選択のいくつかを読むことができます。
ここでは、コピー記号と記号が論理と記号論を介してどのようにリンクされているかについての講義が行われ
ましたが、特にアブダクションに進むので、これ
は物事の科学とは対照的に、より積極的な
科学とは対照的に、ピアスと記号論の定義について少し説明しました
より形式的な科学である形式の科学
アブダクティヴな推論とは何か
探求するのは非常に魅力的でした
これはアブダクティオからの引用です
彼らが書いた論文では、二次文献では一般的です。
たとえば、ピアスに基づいて、
アブダクションが
2 つの部分または 2 種類の
ジェネレーティブ アブダクションと選択的
アブダクション
で発生していると考えることができます。ここでは、2 つの
タイプまたは 2 つの変種または 2 つの
コンポーネントの 2 ストローク エンジンに関する別の視点があります。
スタンフォード百科事典からのアブダクション
ええと
彼らが哲学文献に書いた哲学
アブダクションという用語は、
2つの関連するが異なる意味
で使用されます 両方の意味でこの用語は
、歴史的に最初の意味で
の説明的推論を指します 仮説を生成する際の説明的推論の場所を指します
それは生成的
誘拐
ですが、現代文学で最も頻繁に使用される意味である2番目の意味では、
列挙された一連の仮説
を正当化または評価する際の説明的推論の場所を指し、ある意味では内容を意味
のあるものにします キュレートされるために生成され
なければならない アイデアは具体化されなければならない
正当化または評価されるために列挙
されました
ディーンディーンはこれを続けてください。これで
赤と青ができました。これは
、両方が必要であることを強調することが非常に重要
でした。説明が次に表示されるには最低2つ必要です。
確率論的意味での
推論は、最良の説明への推論としても知られています。これは、何か
を説明するために最も可能性の高い仮説に目を向ける論理的推論の一形態
です。例えば
、左手の白豆は、右手に
保持された物体の袋から来ました。 ここで、
提唱された仮説が不完全な観察または推論にどのように依存するかを見ることができます。
バッグの中に豆もありますか。たとえそうであっても
、左手に転送されたもののソースは
、そこに到着したときの時間的な深さです。 あなたが
どのような背景とどの
ような文脈を持っ
ているかが、この第 4 の形
の論理に行きます。  y
は一生をかけて、もつれを
解きほぐし、
ある種の一貫性に改革しよう
としました。そして、それに
沿って聞いている人は、
以前の感覚的観察の痕跡を見始めるかも
しれません。世界についての信念の事後更新です。
これらの政策
は期待される自由エネルギーによって評価する
ことができますが、そこ
にたどり着き、アブダクションに目を向けましょう。ここでは、アブダクションに関連するコモンズ
に関する非常に魅力的な論文をいくつか紹介し
ます。 トーマス・キャピタンによる
実用的な推論としてのアブダクションに関するコモンズからのリソース
私たちがすべてを読むつもりはないこの作品
は、仮説生成と仮説選択とのアブダクションのその二重の性質について多くの興味深い点に入り、
仮説
選択
が演繹的に行うことができることを区別します 有効な評価です
が、創造性は段階的です eは
非推論的であり、アイデアを
事前検閲せず
、ブレインストーミングの際に包括的な議論を
行い、限られた空間と時間の中で選別が必要であることを認識し、
さらにここでいくつかの議論があり
ます。
私たち
が自由エネルギーの原則に向かって戻ったり、自由エネルギーの原則と織り交ぜたりするにつれて
、仮説の最初の認識
は、アイデア
の世界への制御されていない
洞察によって、寄せ集められた全体を観察することでもたらされ
ます。
前提 2 の例
論文の前の部分を引用する
ことは、事前の認識によって引き起こされる
その内容は、事実の観察によって示唆される
知覚的観察
しかし、示唆されるすべてが事実の認識から推論されるわけではない
ため、
ピアス
は、
論理的に正確に推論に類似し
ており、それらが unc であることだけを受け入れる 意識的で
あり、したがって制御不能であり、
したがって批判の対象とならないので
、ここで
無意識のプロセスが制御可能であると見なすことができるかどうかなどの質問はさておき
、私たちは知覚のヒントを無意識の推論として非常に多く見てい
ます。また
、注意と
意識の
意識的推論
と他の潜在意識の推論のプロセス間の連続性も見ています。
ある意味で、これはまた
、知覚学習の統合されたフレームワークを提供します
信念 時間的深さの更新
意識的および無意識的な認識
これらの機能はすべて
ペルシャの作品で探求されており、アブダクションの
論文はその事実を非常に具体的に
強調
しています もう少し、
アブダクションとレトロダクション
、この 1 人のディーンに何か追加したいことはあります
か。つまり、それを研究し、分析した人々は、これが
形態学であったかどうか、または
2 つの用語を同時にまたは
同じ意味で
再び使用できるかどうかについて、時々不思議に思います。 それはおそらく1つです
詳細を知り
たい場合は、おそらく興味深いので見てみる必要がありますが、
現時点では基本的にやりたいことはすべて
ここにあるわけではありません。
驚くべき事実の配列から推測に導か
れるプロセス
それらを説明するために多くの理論を使用してきた 多くの
論理学者はこの最後の推論と呼ぶことを拒否している 多くの論理学者
は、その結論が非常に
問題が多く、尋問以上の量になるため、この最後の推論と呼ぶことを拒否している
私は彼らが間違っていると確信していますが、
彼らは推論の真の科学的
定義を
持っていません. 物事の推測された状態
は、物事の実際の状態に似ている
傾向があるという漠然とした意味でありそうで
あり、私はこれがそうである部分
です at は、私たちが
器楽主義
として定義するものは何でも、その器楽主義に取って代わり
ます これもまた
難問の 1 つです
。
最終的にはそれがここでの
質問で
あり、アブダクション論文
の著者の1人の以前の研究のいくつかを読む価値があり
、彼らの研究で開発と開発の強い線を見ることができます。
多くの作業を拡張し、近代化し
ましょう。
ええと、クマのサインを下に置い
たのは、本当に
本当に簡単な話をしたいから
です。クマがいる場所に住んで
いる場合、クマのサインが点灯している場合、人々はそのサイン
を無視し始めます。 実際の
標識
オブジェクト
と彼らはもはや通訳にはなりません
彼らは意図的に
そのトライアドを失い
ます.
男性の連絡先
サインアップする
とき、そして最も重要なことはサインを削除するときは非常に選択的でなければなら
ないので、それをそこに
掲載したかったの
です。
アブダクションを機能させること
は
、実際に
強調を作成する可能性の除去
です。その後の議論でアブダクションに戻ってくるので、リアリズムと道具主義に進むと思い
ます。フェアベンドの論文からの引用です
リアリズムによれば、そのような知識の
事実上の知識
は、宇宙の一般的または特定の特徴を記述して
いるため
、重力のモデルが重力であるという意味ではなく
、重力のモデルが重力の対象であるという意味ではありません
が、現実主義者は
たとえば、重力の正式なモデルは、重力によって作用する物体
の存在を教えてくれ、
重力が作用
する力の記述を認可
することに注意してください。 直接見たり聞いたり感じたりすることはない
が、それでも顕著な
影響
力を持っている 力は実在
する 道具主義によれば実在する
完全に正しい理論でさえ
何も説明しない
が、
その経験的内容を構成する事実を予測する
ための道具として役立つ 再びこのニュートンの
重力の例では、楽器奏者
は、実体は存在しないという立場を取ることができます
重力と重力
場
は、単に統計的議論の道具的応用
であり
、潜在的に社会的または
権力の動的議論でさえ
あり、楽器奏者はこの
中で物体の
実体と力の存在を否定するかもしれません 場合によっては
、道具
としての言葉
やコミュニケーションに関する関係、
そしてそれがどのように感覚データを順序付けて予測するかについて懐疑的なレベルまで物事を取り上げ
ます。
私たちはストリーム上でリアリズムと道具主義をかなり探求し
、メルアンドリュースの作品で多くのことを強調しました。
ライブ ストリーム番号で 14.
リアリズムと器楽主義についてのスライドをもう 1 枚。
それからどちらか
お気軽にどうぞ。
一番下のスライドのいくつかをもう一度説明します。
地図の領域の区別は
、リアリズムと器楽主義の会話の非常に重要な要素です。
さまざまな優れた哲学的研究も行われています。
実在論の後継者、
反実在論
、私が言うところのこれら2つは
否定であり、
私たちが提案している実在論と道具主義は反対であると見なされる可能性があります。
また、ヘレン・ロンガノの
科学的多元主義に関する研究は、これについて多くのことを述べ
ています。
リアリズムと器楽主義に関する学際的なレンズ
、そして学部長は、
あなたが見つけたこのトップ論文について何か説明したいですか?
正直に言うと、これは壮大な計画で覚え
ていません.多くの論文と論文が
ありました. 繰り返しになりますが
、一時停止してトレイルをたどりたい人のために、たくさんのテキストを掲載して
います。
y リアリズムの道具主義についてのコメント
私がよく思い浮かべるのは、
これらすべてが
何らかのレベルで行動の中で支えられているということです。そのため
、
さまざまな
矛盾やさまざま
なレトロな
アプローチを探すという考えが
当てはまる可能性があります。 あなたが知っている森の中を
誰かが道をたどることを考えているとき
、
またはあなたがこれらのことの多くを再具現化することができると想像するか、
またはおそらくあるレベルのすべてが
何らかの具現化を経て、
具現化がちょうど起こっているという概念的なとき より
コンセプチュアルな空間
で、他の多くの
種類の物語に依存したり
、物事を通して自分のやり方を感じたりすること
はありません。実践の分野にいるときに起こる違いは、その中にいることにとても慣れているということです。
その具現化が
あなたが泳ぐ水に
なるという実践の分野です。それは
、この偉大なはいディーンに関連するものになる可能性が
あり
ます。
sm
器楽主義に
はい はい 最後まで し
ないか
元に戻す
ここに小さなアンパサンドがありました ここに私
たち そしてここに
ええと 認知のためにここで1つの簡単なメモ
ここでは深入りしませんが、4e
はxiavioとvan derのように参照できます
非常に魅力的な分野である音楽教育学の文脈にあった schiff 2018 論文 4e は具現化さ
れています 埋め込まれた 埋め込まれた
拡張された 制定された
文化など 7e 11e 22e それらすべてと、2021 年の応用アクティブ推論シンポジウム
からのカール・フリステンからの楽しい引用
彼は、能動的推論の重要な点の 1 つ
は、それが予測
処理を超えていることであり、知覚を超え
ていることであり、知覚が
アクティブで
あり、あなたが話していることを明確にするために、4 つの e によって実際に象徴される今世紀初頭の実用的な転換を強調または反映していることです。
紫色の円形の因果関係とそこにあるものは何でも、個人または植物との
あらゆる粒子との関与の循環的な因果関係について、
それは非常に簡単です
これらの詳細には立ち入るつもりはありませんが
、非アクティブな論文に関連する一連の研究を以下に示します。
その他の背景の
引用や
調査したいと思わ
れるその他の研究、アブダクティブな論文
、および
願わくば、ここにリストさ
れている著者による多くの以前の論文
と、再び多くの素晴らしい仕事との唯名論の役割と関係について、著者が私
たちのために解き明かしてくれることを願っています。
2 つの論文またはその間のスペースに入ることができます 2 つの論文
の最初の並置を見
てみましょう 私たちのビデオは
ここで氷山の一角になるので、ディーン
あなたは氷山の一角です あなたは何
を言いたいですか 私が言ったように、これらの2つの論文について
最初に並置し
て
ください
私が実行したい状況分析の中で、
矛盾を取り除こうとするか、
統合
を定式化したいと思います。その場所に戻ったら
、
あなたの例をあなたのハイパー、
ハイパー
、あなたの頭 主題はサブ uh
状況分析です。あなたの例
は、
あなたが私のやり方
を言うのを間違え
てい
ないということでフィッティング
します。
現在
、比較が
あり、ここには書かれておらず、準備が整っています。
基本的には
、
論文が2つの異なる焦点について話している各論文内の例を選択しました
が、それらはまだアクティブの
このより大きな
限界
境界内にあります 推論と、どのように
アクティブな推論
が注意の体制内
の行動の周りで振る舞い
、それをそれよりも利用可能な何かに開いているか.
詳細または規模にやさしい
ことは、心の理論が必然
的に積極的な推論と融合
するか、到着した瞬間の誘拐
が実際
に私の感覚ウィンドウを正しく拡張するために楽器を使用する可能性を否定するという考え
ですか?
他のものを引き出すのにかなりの時間がかかりますが、
人々が実際に見たい場合は、
約2枚の紙を並べて配置すると
、大量の類似点を見つけることができます。
これは一種の興味深い演習です。
時間はかかり
ますが、実際にそれらを見ると
それぞれが並んで絡み合っています
たくさんの編組が行われ
ています ディーン・スティーブンに感謝します ええ
、ディーンが話していたように、これが好きです あなた
はこれらの2つの論文を手に入れました 彼らの哲学
が親切な2つの氷山のように見えるかもしれません
冷凍さ
れた形と形で、
下と上に物
がありますが、その間に水があり、エビ
がたくさん入っている可能性があり
ます あらゆる種類の
ものが泳いでいるので
、ここのこのリスト
では、リアリズムの道具主義が
うまくいっていると思います。それらはあなたの2つの氷山です。
私たちはそれらを素敵でシャープにしたいと思ってい
ます。
それらをオフにしてから、統計
とモデルの比較
を
行ってください 彼らはまだそこにいることを知っていますが、
彼らは少しジャイブするかもしれません マルチエージェントの
信念のコミュニケーション ああ、
ここに何かが流れています
組み立てられたアンサンブルとしての物事 申し訳ありません
アンサンブルとしてのモデルの
視点
またはタイツの視点、またはそれらの
視点は、
確率論の複雑なシステム
などを知る方法から来ています
。ええと、私たちは今、氷山を
溶かしていないかどうかはわかりません。
氷山がそこにあるということではありませんが、私たちは それらは
さまざまなタイプの
方法であり
、おそらくより柔軟で安定性が低くなり始めている
ので、非アクティブな論文に進み
、物事を合理的に保ち、その論文
で議論することがたくさんあります もう 2 つ
は、一時停止して楽しむためにスライドに多くのコンテンツを
追加する
ことです。ほとんどのコンテンツは紙からコピーおよび引用されているため
、ロードマップの順序で説明します。
論文が通過する重要な部分のいくつかなので
、非アクティブな論文のセクション 1
では、世界の他者を理解するための 2020 年
の Vessier の議論の要約から始めます。
トムは心の理論である
1 つの前提として、他の心を通して考えるという議論を要約または捉える
1 つの社会的認知は非アクティブ
で具体化されている 2 つの非アクティブで具体化されて
いる 社会的行為者は社会的認知を直接把握できない
3 直接把握できないもの
はすべて推論されなければならない
したがって、非活動的で
具現化された社会的認知
が推論されなければならない 社会的認知とその著者についての推論が存在しなければならない
非アクティブな紙の
状態 前提 2 と 3 によって
、トムはトムの正統性に加わり、
世界と他の人を理解することは、精神状態
を推測し、それらに帰する能力に
帰着します。
この重要な分析では、そのような
トムアカウントは実際に
活動主義者とこの
幸せな結婚をしている.
p1 と p2 の間の矛盾は
、その t2m 引数の 2 つの隠れた仮定から生じる
ので、ここでは上記の p123 を見て
、1 つの
社会的認知が
明示的な命題形式の情報
心的表象と帰属
彼らはこれを言おうとしている 彼らは
このように感じている 精神的
表現
と隠された仮定も社会的
認知は
、例えば出生時などの推論のための概念と論理ツールに組み込まれ
ています。後続のセクションでは、前提1と2の間の矛盾を分析して明確にします
社会的認知がそうではない場合の緊張 活動的で
具現化されているの
は本当なのか、それとも
社会的認知は
そのような社会的アクターによって直接把握できないという矛盾した主張なのか、
彼らは
非活動的な視点から
これらの仮定の根底にある問題を批判的に評価しようとしています
隠れた仮定とその
理由 活動家はこれらの隠された
仮定
を拒否し、したがって上記の前提を拒否し、
社会的行動におけるこれらの非代表的な方法と共構築のメカニズム
が
何であるかを探求するつもりです。
ここで前に見
た内部状態と外部状態
との調停
ブランケット状態による内部状態と外部状態
パール 1988 の定義
によると、
内部状態と外部状態を
条件付きで独立させるブランケット状態で
ある 時々、人々はさらに進ん
で、ブランケット
状態 b
が 2 種類の状態に分割される
フリステン ブランケットについて説明します。
そして、これらの 2 種類の状態は
、内部状態の
統計的依存関係の観点から入ってくることによって定義されます。感覚的状態
と外向きの統計的依存関係
は
、エンティティまたはモノからニッチへのアクションまたはインターフェイスとして解釈
できますが、マルコフ ブランケットに戻ります。
さらに後で、
はい、スティーブンは
、
実際にはこの前のスライドのページに戻ってきただけですが、
これに関連して、物事を直接することはできないと言われて
います。直接よく把握
できることがいくつかあります。
有用な区別です。なぜなら
、ええと、グリップについて話しているからです。
グリップまたは
ペンチで、ホットパイプを直接握ることはできません
ペンチが必要です 直接
ええと、おそらく複数のツールがなければ多くのことを行うことはできませんが、物事を
つかむことについて話すとき、または
人々が何かについて考えているとき、
何かが明確に命題である
と理解することを知っている
とき、私たちが言葉について考えているときでさえ、他の種類のツールが作用する可能性があることを知っています。
これらすべての
ものを帰する行為は、 すべてのレベルでツールを使用している
ため、セクション 2 で氷山が
どのように溶けるかによって、ここで興味深いブレンドが行われて
います。論文で読むか、ここで一時停止し
て多くの側面を捉えることが
できます。彼らは仮定に疑問を投げかけます
社会的認知は精神的表現に還元され
、他者を理解することは
、共有された非明示的な
意味
と潜在的にいくつかの
アブダクティブな意味に熟練することの問題であるため、それらのポイントを抽出することができます.
ディンディンディンおよびモデルベースの推論
はすべて、コンテキスト固有の
変更可能で
動的であり、
以降の段落で展開します。
最初の 2 つの前提の間には、本当に
アキレス腱のような明白な矛盾があります。 または、セクション 2 で論理をターゲットにするソフト スポットである
彼らは、社会的認知が生まれながらに組み込まれているという 2 番目の仮定に疑問
を投げかけようとしています。
たとえば、純粋な生まれつきの視点のようなネイティブ主義者の立場を保持し
ていません。
文化がどのように獲得されるかの発達および生態学的ダイナミクスに焦点を当てている
ためです。彼らはスターターパックの獲得に疑問を投げかけてい
ます。 たとえば、セクション 3 の社会的認知に関するハードワイヤードな視点に対する非活動主義者の批評は
、頭の中で強調する仮説を批判しています。
他の心を通して考えることに内在する矛盾
彼らは別の関係を提案しようとしている
ああ、あなたはその料理が嫌いです
これを試してみましょう.
これは
動的システム理論
または
dstからのアプローチになるでしょう. このセクションは、ニッチを構築するエージェントの社会文化的に位置付けられた実践
について学習し、
予測力を生成するのに役立つアプローチです。
これは、dst がその中核に
、創発非線形性や自発性などの有用なツールを
備えているためです。
精神のトム理論のような社会的認知理論は、
したがって、存在論的仮定を作ることを控えるべきである
存在論的ここでは、物事が世界でどのようにあるかについてである
ため、コンピュータ科学の知識管理よりもむしろ哲学者の存在論のほうが多い 存在論の
意味
人は作ることを控えるべきである これらの
種類の存在論的仮定
は、複合体についてのリアリズムによってライセンスされています 扱いやすいモデルに基づいたシステムで
あるため、モデルが
扱いやすいから
といって、存在論的仮定を行うライセンスがあるとは限りません。
扱いやすいモデルは
、複雑な動作について学習する機会であるため、
認識論的な主張のみ
が許可
されているためです。 扱いやすくするための主張を見てください。
次のように静的関係によって動的システムを表すことができます。ここに
、以下のキャプション付きの方程式 1 2 と 3 が
あります。
彼らは
、動的システムのカーネルのような非常に単純な種類を使用しています。
理論は
、
物事がどのように大まかに変化するかの関数であることを理解することであり、
それ
は後継モデルの観点からいくつかの異なる方法で表現され、より多く
の変化モデルの光線として表されます
これはモデル化アプローチ
であるという意味
でもあるため、モデルのフィッティングではなく、モデルが私たちに何を伝えているのか見てみましょう
多くの場合
、定義されたオントロジーがあれば、最終的に何が起こる
かを知っ
ている
アプローチ
です
それは
ある意味でのスタンスであることを知っています。それ
は脚を離して保持し
ていて、私は開脚を行っていますか、それとも
脚を正しく組ん
でい
ますか？誰か専門家が教えてくれます
はい、ありがとう、ディーン、ありがとう、
はい、スティーブンが今まで言っていたことに付け加え
たいと思います。
構成主義の作品であるという論文が大好き
です。
私たちがその決定を下すことができるように
するために、
それは分割ですか、それともフォークですか、それは
文字通りフォークですか、
左から右に移動する必要がある代わりに、
脱構築
が必要です。
なぜなら、彼らは
自律性を尊重している
と思うからであり、彼らは素晴らしい仕事
をしたと思うからです この論理は大丈夫
です 他の著者がたどったこの演繹的な道
は必ずしもここには当てはまらないかもしれません
それはあまりにも多くのブレンドを引き起こすので、
あなたはあなたが実際に左右のものを保持して
いますが、あなたは追加を省略しています.
あなたがそれを見る唯一の方法は、あなたが再構築する前に解体することができるかどうかであり、解体することは、それが
すでに存在することを区別することを意味
するわけではあり
ません。
私は急いで
次に左に行くべきか右に行くべき
かを考えているので、特に全体的な文脈で特にそうです、スティーブン
ここで簡単なポイントを与えたい場合は、
それに追加してください
状況のその部分
ええと、それが何が起こっているのかを認識するようになる場所だと私は信じています.
科学
は私たちに何が起こっているのかを非常に伝えてい
ます
. チーム チーム エイジ ジャンクションまたは
何か
最終的には、それがどこにあるかという認識部分
があり、アクティブな
推論では、多くの場合、より
複雑であり、方法
の正確さについての科学的存在とあいまいです。また、
アクティブな推論では、認識と複雑さが生じる場合
があります。
論文の後半まで続けて、
彼ら
は私たちの多くが大好きな複雑さについて多くのことを話して
いる 複雑さ 複雑さ 科学
複雑さ理論は非常に多くの
素晴らしい
用語をもたらします 概念 人々 メソッド ツール
アイデア すべて
そして彼らはオートポリシーとこの再帰性について多くのことを話します
そのため
、非アクティブな論文で作成された非常に創造的なリンケージがたくさんあり、複雑さは
セクション 4 で非常に価値のある方法で使用され
ます。
非アクティブなダイナミックな設定でアクティブな推論に移行します。
そこでは、文化的な共同構築の根底にあるダイナミクスについて学び、理解するため
の洞察に満ちた手段としてアクティブな推論が展開されます。
必ずしもエージェントを必要としないことを考慮すると
、受動的な
エージェントはお互いの状態の作成者であり
、頭
の中にギアがあり、ギアがより分散されているようになった先に示した非アクティブな図に似て
います。 図 2 の体
と心に
は、
古典的な
意味とモデルに基づいた推論があります。ここでは、
さまざまな社会的アクターが、
この推論的なアカウントを持って
いるようなものです。
図 3 では
、図 2 の社会的行動を、ここで内部状態
にラベル付けするという観点からアクティブな推論の下で描いています。
社会的アクター
と外部状態が社会的
アクター 1 であるため、これは
社会的アクター 2 の観点からのもので
あり、包括的な状態が
社会文化的な意味として組み立てられており、その
モデルに基づいた推論は、分散され制定され
た推論アカウントに開かれています。
[音楽]
願わくば、もっと詳しく説明したいと思います。
これは、彼らが社会
的非活動的空間へ
の能動的推論の積極的な楽器演奏家の適用を支持しているからです。
そして、彼らは
社会的場面を科学的実践に類似したものとして
特徴付けていると書い
ています。 たとえば
、特定のコンテキストで実験室で何が起こっているか、さらには特定のコンテキストで実験室で
何が起こっているかについての特定の見解を取り上げ
、特定のコンテキスト
でそれを批判し、実験室
の廊下で何が起こっているかについてもう少し拡張的に考えます。
そして地下室
と建物の周りの世界で
、それもまたrです
黄色のブロンバーグとうまく結びついている
予測する脳に関する
研究は科学者ではなく
、生態学的な観点から非活動的な視点にも焦点を当てている科学者ではなく、
必ずしも社会的なものだけで
なく、社会的な
もの
は表1の重要なケース
です. 自然界に関連する
いくつかの仕切りと
細胞の内容、および
科学的なツールと構造
について
もう少し詳しく説明します。これ以降の議論でここに戻るので、
表1
をチェックし
てください。
曲線のようなものを描く
文字のように見えるものを丸で囲み
ますか いくつかの三角形を描きますか
別の行を追加します
か テンソルにしますか 強調する
別の二重境界線だけでも、表 1 に他に何を描きますか
ディーンと同じように完璧
だと私が言うのは、あなたが行って
これを見て、なぜこれらの
ハイパーパラメータとなぜ
これらが遅いのかを自問することだけです
rals それは私にとってあらゆる種類の幸福につながると思うので、それはちょうど私を楽しませてくれました。
混乱
これは
、トムのような理論に似たトムが保持する 2 つの隠れた仮定を批判的に分析するときに明らかで
あり、非活動主義によって拒否される 2 つの
秘密の仮定は
、リンケージの評判を落とし
、共構築
的な性質と組み込まれた生態系の
要素を繰り返します。 彼らは、社会的
不作為の再帰と
経時展開、社会的
不作為の展開
、動的システム
理論
と
動的システムモデリングの一種として道具的に適用される能動的推論
が有望
であり、社会理解を次のように考えるための適切で補完的なツールであることを示唆しています。
特定の方法で保持された一般
化された同期。  aper そして
それは今度
はアブダクティブペーパーとペアになるので
、アブダクションに移る前に一呼吸
はい、スティーブン
はその息を吸い
ますええと、それがどのようにほとんど橋になり得るかについての最後の文
は、それらは
補完的なええと
、動的システム理論の使用です
ギャップを埋めている 彼らはギャップを埋めているのだ ある意味で
、拉致に関する論文について話している
と、埋められていないギャップがいくつかあると思い
ます。 ギャップを埋めているとしましょう。
アブダクション
も感じるかもしれないので
、アクティブな推論の美しさを知っているとしましょう。
ベイジアンアプローチは
、さまざまなスケールとモダリティがたくさんあり、
重み付けしてブレンドして、潜在的に何を感じるかを与えることができます。
正しいことをする
ことは、他の素晴らしい相互拉致を除外することを意味しないことを意味
します。
私たちは鈍化させます.論文は、私たちが以前に説明した論文の重要なポイントのいくつかへの比較的短く、非常に簡潔な紹介から始まります. 彼らの目的
は、cs pierce の後期、
例えば 1903 年以降または 1905 年以降の
作品の自然主義的な表現に興味を持っていることであり、コンテキストのセクションで取り上げた、アブダ
クティブ推論の記号論的および論理的
概念を解き明かすほとんど未発表の作品
です。 針に糸を通す誘拐の生物学的モデル 生物
の機能的完全性を維持するものは何でも 生地を
織る その
生物の存在
と現代の神経科学との互換性のための進化
上の義務 彼らは忠誠心と同盟に焦点を当てています
前に話しましたが
、導入部でも
マルコフブランケットの概念を紹介します。
これは、
社会的不作為と誘拐を伴う積極的な推論を伴う前線である場合のように、もう少し詳細を追加するための並置の優れたポイントと
なります。 インターフェース前面内のホットポイントまたは接点のようなもの
で、
実際にズームインします
これら2つのモデルで使用されている内部状態
であり、アクティブな推論
オントロジーが非常に価値がある場所です。
なぜなら、人々が異なる言語で話している場合でも
、
コンピュータープログラムを使用して方程式、詩、
そして科学
論文をリンクして積極的にリンクできる場合でもです。 アクティブな推論オントロジーを使用するか、
事前に注釈を付け
ます。私たちは、両方とも月を指している
が、あなたの指は私の指なのか
、同じ指を指し
ているのですか?
少し離れて、あなたの光線は
私の視点から月を
逃しています.
単純
に共鳴点
だけで打っ
たり走ったりするよりも
いくつかの共通点をまとめることができる方法がある
ので、あなたが今言ったことに追加したいのはこれ
だけです。それに1つ追加するだけ
です。申し訳ありませんが、ええと
、違いがあるかもしれない
ので、
多くの用語のこの理解がある可能性があります 存在論的
理解 そして
、しばしば問題になるのは、何かが
整合していないが、
単に気付かれていないか、またはブラシで塗りつぶされている場合です。
そうでなければ、この空間には非常に多くの存在論的
なものが浮かんでいて、
それがその美しさであり、
あなたが何を見つけることは認知的に不可能だからです。 ありがとう次のセクションをもう一度見る必要があります。
これらの 2 つのライトを
共照明します。共構築します
。2 つのライトは物理的に重なら
ないため、視差が生じる必要があります。 これらの
2 つの光と影、そしてあらゆる種類の
効果によって、同じ
波長ではないかもしれません。おそらく、あなたは
歩き回っていて、別の側には
別の
イルミネーションがあります。
1800 年代後半から 1900 年代前半に開発された、
ほぼ
準アルゴリズム的ではある
が確実
に計算前の
フレームワークを取り上げ、
インターフェースを開始し、
それがアクティブな推論にどのように関連するかを確認して、
より多くのことを強調できるようにします。
さらなる
セクションなので、これをすべて読みたい、または論文を読みたい場合は一時停止し
てください。ただし、それらは後半のスキーマに焦点を当てています。
はい、ディーンを
お願いします。
照明は実際
に財布を試し
てみ
まし
た.  2つの制約の中
で私たちが今見ることができるエネルギーのレベルの試合.
ええと
、バイスグリップに戻るパラメータ化のアイデア.
先に論じたように、仮説の発見の論理に例えることができます。これは、
生成的な創造的要素と、
ベイジアンモデル選択ベイジアンモデル
削減のような二次的な選択的要素
を持ち、ピアソンアブダクションの完全な同化は起こり得ないという警告的な発言を追加することさえあり
ます
これは
、2 ストローク エンジンの半分である最良の説明への推論であり、一般的に、
人々はアブダクションを使用
して、特定のセットからの確率論的推論を参照し
ます。この後のスキーマ
は、1903 年以降のものですが、
専門家にとって、驚くべき要因 e の観察から始まる研究は最も少ない
ものでした。
観察の驚き
を発散し、条件付きの大前提を通じて
、ピアーズが調査官と呼んだムードで再び結論付けます。
それは、それが持っているようなものであり、まさにその中に
あり、それは、何か緊急に重要なことを行うべきであるということです。
好奇心によって
不確実性が減少する エントロピー
は、意味のある質問の定式化につながり
、
調査者の気分やその他の
気分についてのより多くの議論がある
今後の数回のライブストリームで、その重要性を
もう少し
からかうことができると思い
ます。彼らは研究の経済性に関するこの問題を継続する予定です。
そのため
、アクティブな推論との接触領域を実際に特定した 3 つの議論コースを形成しました。
彼らが提案している拉致は、主演する最初のトリオ
またはトライアド
を形成します t
能動的推論とアブダクティブ推論の間の忠誠を形成するために
最初に
非退化的な三項関係の存在、
次にアブダクティブ推論の主要な原則の利用
b および 3 番目に仮定法による条件付き
定式化
いくつかの論理的な専門性
が散りばめられてい
ますが、それがストリームの目的です
一時停止してテキストを読むことができるポイントで、
彼らはマルコフ
ブランケットの概念、
またはむしろ
フリストとブランケットとしての現実主義者の解釈を強調
し
、マルコフブランケットが再び
現実主義者の最初のブランケットの意味で実装されたと主張します。
外部の内部状態の間の仲介者としての境界に焦点を当てた還元不可能な
トライアディック形式、したがって記号論で生じる三次性には
、さらに多くのことを言う必要が
ありますが、どちらかが b の OK についてもう 1 つのポイントを与えたい場合、
彼らは次のように続けます。 推論
の指針となる原則のいくつかについて話し
、特に ab について話し合う
推論を導く際の誘導の役割
能動的推論の主な原理は何か
ここでは
、自由エネルギーの変分または
境界の驚きとして期待される能動的推論の技術的な詳細を説明し
、それをいくつか
の主要な理論に結び付けます 表現や意味などについて私たちが行ってきた多くの議論にも関連しているピアスの情報源と
生物記号論の議論
と、
それはさらに、またはより深いところにある
、
結合主義の
議論と、この
普遍的な心の問題につながります。
いくつかの点で力の老化です 普遍的な
認知 汎認知ダイナミクス
分散型認知システムの
問題は von Schiller の effete mind で
あり、その後、彼らは
手付かずの毛布とその構造
についてトライアド関係の観点から議論する予定です
ピアソン トライアド サイン オブジェクト アリ
は未踏につながる
これらのより広い質的スレッドのいくつかをまとめるセマンティックな可能性
i  n
動的システム理論の可能性のある記号論的分析
量的ベイジアン法
と能動的推論
が実装するツールキットとともにもたらすその他すべて
の
もの 可能であれば、記号論的命題の
非常に
興味深いが微妙な論理的
構成要素
を展開する予定です
さらなる議論で
それをさらに掘り下げますが、
条項または主張と
令状の間の論理関係のさまざまなフレーミングと、このすべてのレトリック
が
リアリズムの
誘拐
と
ピアスのバージョンのリアリズムに
どのように関連しているかを探る予定です。
はい、可能である
が現実化できないものがあります。次に
、その隣接または
実現可能
な可能性に何を使用し、それをどこで使用したいのか
、その対称性を破る
ものはどこでプラグマティズムなのか、検討するのに役立つものは何でしょう
発生する可能性のあるすべての可能性
の空間
考慮していなかったが実際に起こった隣接する可能性に驚くことはありません。そして、起こり得ない可能性を検討する
ために
、少し余分な考えやいくつかの
余分なコンピューターリソースを費やすことはそれほど悪くないかもしれ
ません
が、私たちは望んでいません 起こり得ない
指数関数的な
可能性のある空間で迷子になり、起こりうる可能性への
焦点と注意を失うことになります。
これは、ピアス
が真の可能性として説明するもので
あり、プラグマティストのスタンス
とムード
もまた、政策の選択とループを閉じます。
積極
的な推論におけるプラグマティズム
ベイン・パリの定式化における信念のプラグマティストの意味は
、その人
が行動できるもので
あり、そこには多くの共鳴が
あるということです。
スケールフレンドリーまたはレベルについて話します。
または
、
これが存在する
ことを可能にするある種の構造を知っています。 ここで
それ
を見る方法があるので、完全に下に行き、細胞レベルに引き下げられ
たという感覚があります。
ええと、記号表現のこれらのアイデアを見ているのは大丈夫です
が、アクティブな推論でそれが
そうではないことを知っています
処理され集約される信号が入ってくると信じている
ので、形態形成
を持っている構造を持っている一種のスケールが
あり、
一時
停止の標識が意味をなすスケールに到達して、
ええと、そのように解釈される 自分の
記号表現なので
、ここの非活動家の間でこの緊張
が起こり、それが起こる可能性がある場所かもしれないと思いますが、議論
はうまくいくと
思います. それ
は実現可能
です。ディーンだけです。その後
、残りをすばやく移動します。
ここで本当に簡単にしましょう。特に b
と、程度が低くなるまで、c
はバスだと思います。 突き刺すような
思考
を積極的な推論領域に取り入れる方法の重要
性は、仮定に基づいて構築されています。
つまり、私たちの継続
的な存在、継続的な
現実は、世界のツールを使用して
より多くの経験を蓄積していることを意味します。
世界
とプールとプールとは、スティーブンがそれを取り上げてくれてありがとうと言っていた集合体を意味します
.2つの密度の具体化の密度物語としてこの集合体を書き留めたいと思った
ので、再び私は
あなたがあなたのことを知りません
すべてが現実であると排他的に言い
、その下にあるすべての例
もまた現実である
と言う
.
それは
どのようにして
これらの密度を形成することを可能
にするのですか？ 実際、私たち
が熟考しなければならないことは
、スクリプトまたは少なくとも構文を反転させ
、アクティブな推論に照らしてアブダクションについて話すこと
です。ここで、ジェネレーティブ
アブダクションを備えた 2 ストローク エンジン
と 選択的
アブダクション
であり、それ
から、
選択的アブダクション
をサンプリング
プロセスとして見ること
や、生成的アブダクションがどこに適合するかを理解することなどの観点から、
それを能動的推論のオントロジーのいくつかに結びつけ、
アクティブな推論の光からアブダクションを見ていきます
私たち
は、アクティブな
推論を、英語では
話せない概念について必ずしも話すことができない概念として解釈するのではなく、アクティブな推論のオントロジーの観点からフレーミングまたはアブダクションを見るように言うように操作することさえ
できますが、英語では話せませんが、 私たちは
英語の単語
を使うことができるので、同じようにアクティブな infe について必ずしも話す必要はありません。
これらが何をすべきか、何をすべきでないかを言うのは最後ですが
、アクティブな推論オントロジーを使用することは可能であり
、それは一種の 2 ステップ チェックリストのようなもの
であり、コア サプリメントまたは
含意セクション
は、そのマルチスケールのコンテキストでその状況
で意味をなす実用的な方法で使用されました。
実際には、
私たちが話し
ているのではなく、アクティブな推論を使用して
話しているかどうかを尋ねる 2 段階のプロセスです。 アクティブな推論自体の擁護者や
営業担当者のように
、彼ら
は fap フレームワークの意味
での用語を使用
してケースを再記述し、内部状態と外部状態の関係を強調します。
状態はブランケットを介して仲介され、
次にこの三段論法
を経て、アブダクティブアクティブ推論の質的スキーマを再構築および再
記述し、この
アクション認識
ループ
を記述します。 入ってくる感覚情報を危険にさらし
、それ
をベイジアン生成モデルのコンテキストで受動
的または能動的に解釈する
だけでなく
、調査員のその気分で展開されている
何かを継続して取り入れます。
ええと、研究の経済の重要な突き刺すような考えな
ので、うまくいけば著者と一緒にこれをもう一度検討します。
ええと、それ
は1970年または1876
年の研究の経済に関する
ピアスの最初の論文に関連しています 効用
と費用の間、
そして具体的には
、この社会的に
制定された実用的な意味での研究に関連することになるでしょう。
お金の時間とエネルギーの支出が与えられた場合、どのように
して知識に最も価値のある追加を得る
ことができるかを尋ねることによって、私の目がどのような実験を行うことができるかを
尋ねます。 最も多くの情報を
得るに
は、研究者
が未証明を減らすためにどのような実験を行うことができるか
自然のシステムについて最も重要なのは、
彼らが知っていることを検証するだけでなく、彼らが知っている
ことを単に改ざんすることで
はなく、むしろ
この最適な実験空間に存在し
、突き刺し、後で著者
が自然化する
ことです
その最適な
実験は培養されており、
エネルギーを使用し、試薬を使用しているため、お金
の時間とエネルギーがどのように発生するかをよく
尋ねることで認知領域を改善します。
いいえ、彼
はそうではありませんでした。彼らはこの研究の経済性についてもう少し議論しました。
彼らはこのセクションで
、ピアスがどのように
いくつかの
価値、美徳、または性質
を促進するかを説明しています。 巧みにブレイクすることで限界利益の減少
を回避する経済的性質としての統合と
注意 質問
を一連の小さな質問
に落とし込み、合理的な投資の制限で答えることができる
いくつの興味深いスレッドが
まとめ
られているか たとえば
、バイナリに分解された質問 はい いいえ 質問
は情報理論と量子にも接続できます
ここでディーン 公正を期すためにお話しさせていただきます。
公正を期すために
、この論文の冒頭で簡単に説明しますが、
fep の道具主義的解釈はなく
、マルコフ毛布などの成分
ですが、これはこの論文の脚注ですが、私たちの
信念です。  fep のより良い言葉と
現実主義者の信任状の 1 つは
、プラグマ プラグマティストの楽観主義、または
むしろ、このリアリズムへのプラグマティストのアプローチが高揚した人々を不快にさせる場合、生存の最大化に貢献する進化的進化的に有用なプロセス間の同盟からの利益についてのアメリリアリズムの行為です。
確固たる形而上学的
基準を求める人の
好み これについて興味深いの
は、リアリズムがあるという考えを保持することは
非常に簡単に擁護できる立場であるという
ことだと思いますが、前のスライドでさえ、直接または少なくとも
言わずに最初に話したことの1つです
それらの引用
は、
その最適な位置は
、搾取または経済
または単純さの何らかの要素であるか、または
私の前
に誰かがこれを行っ
たということ
でした.
特定の結果に
それが現実で
あり、繰り返し
になりますが、このプレーには非常に現実的な部分があるという主張に反対
する
つもりはありません。 実際のところ、私は
これらの著者に完全に同意するのと同じ
ように、共同構築のアイデアについて他の著者に完全に同意するので
、
あなたがあなたであるかどうかは
わかりません. あなた
はイエスとイエスともう一度イエスと言うことができます。
スティーブン
ええ、そこで言われていることに追加するようなもので
あり、
実装または
利用のアイデアは間違いなくほのめかさ
れてい
ます。
私は
、アインシュタインが彼のマインドゲームでこれらすべてを行った
ように、客観的なドメインの中で探求自体を得ることはできないと主張します。
今日起こっていることのいくつかは
それが混ざり合ったものであり、それが元に戻さ
れ、モデル化され、実験されたものであるという意味で、ある意味で構築された精神的なものです。つまり、
モデリングは興味深いものだと思います。
それは
実験ではできないことかもしれません。これ
は昔のジョークの要約です。
eree はあなたが正しいと言う 人
b は b と言う 審判はあなたが正しい
と言う そして c 人は良いと言う a と b は正しくない と
審判はあなたが正しいと知っていると言う
それが好きな人のための少し早口のユーモア
ジャンル
ええと、彼らには結論セクションが
あり、
多くの質問とポイントが
あり、レビンの仕事のフィールドのように、
ここで多くの帰化に戻るための多くの接続があり、
フラットワームの再生能力にもそれを取り入れています。
フラットワームからフラットメイトまで
、今日私たちが行くところです。
また
、マルコフブランケットコンセプトの並置の一部、
特に
非常に重要で
マジードがこれらにもたらした科学の社会的およびアクティブなコンポーネントのいくつかを節約しました
以前の議論は、アブダ
クティブ
な紙と社会的に不活発な紙の
マルコフブランケットとの素晴らしい接触点であり、多くの議論を提供する非常に
制限された技術的な
接触フロントのようなものです。
ドット 1 のイオン
です。ここで
ドット 0 を閉じ
ます。ディーンとスティーブンによる非常に優れた下地処理と
バックパックのパッキング
です。
この時点で追加したいことや
、議論したいことはありますか。 ドット 1 はい、
ディーン、スティーブン、ダニエルの
素晴らしい仕事をご希望の場合
は、通常は
1 つの紙のライブ ストリームから 3 倍のオーダーを行いました
が、それでも 2 時間以内に配信できるようになったので、
それについて拍手喝采を浴びて、
次に
、ドットのちょっとしたヒントとして、
物事がどのように解体されているかを見たいと思っているかどうかについて話しているイスラエル・イスラエル・ヌニェスという名前の研究があります。
製造中の両方の製品を確認する必要があり
ます。例としては、車をどのように製造し、製品で処理
するか、
分岐
点または実際の器具
のいずれかが何であるかなどがあります。
それに沿ってその反転の両方
連続体
は、必ずしも衝突しない場所に物事を持ち込むという点で、あらゆる種類の可能性を開きます。
はい、それらは三つ編みに統合できます。
おそらく、それは
今日以降
、能動的推論を使用している人々が私の中で 意見
は製品であり、プロセスであり、プロセスであり、
製品
であると同時に、それはグリッパーであり
、グリップである
かもしれません。 ある方向に進んでフォークを使用し、
おそらくあなたはそれを拾い、そこで
食事をする他の誰かのためにテーブルセッティングを完了する
ことによってそれを使用する
かもしれ
ませ
ん。 分岐点
はその会話が行われる場所で
あり、私たちのフィールド サイトまたはベース キャンプは
、スティーブン イェーと次の分岐点と道路に出くわすことを想像できる場所です。
著者を連れてくる方法を見つける方法の1つに点を打ってください。あなたが知っている人なら誰でも
、ちょっとした旅をしているかもしれません。
多分、フォークの1つを下って
、湖の端に行き、私たちは入っ
て少し濡れる
必要があるので、どうすればいいですか 科学的
誘拐や、より
科学的に限定された
モデルのようなものは、実験や計測によって立証されたルールである可能性が
あります 大丈夫
いつそれ
が取り除かれるのでしょうか おそらく参加のため おそらく学際的であるため
おそらく変容プロセスのため おそらく
分野の外での深い探査のため えーと これは
、あなたが知っている流砂で立ち往生したり
、深海で溺れたりせずに少し外れるように、ある種の明確な旅のオプションを
正しく与えるにはどうすればよいかについて考えたいと思うかもしれません. ですから、ナビゲートしたいのです
が、これには、
Wazeのオフランプのようなものがある場所と私が考えるポインタのいくつかが与えられていると思います.
オンランプ
ありがとう フェローありがとう